Michelle's been a good friend to me we
have talked about Graham and I and I
constantly tell her how grateful and
thank you for just being in my corner I
just want to I just want to love on her
I've been like listening I've been
paying attention I mean I don't think
she's genuine and I don't think
that she's here for you I think she's
here to put on a show I think she's here
to act like she's someone that she's not
and I'm telling you right now like
I don't think she's right for you
I want to I want to serve him better
than he serves me I want to give him
more than he it's a good competition
don't don't buy it I'm Way too
protective I'm Way too like you're so
freakin it I can't handle it
I'm sorry and I know you tried so hard
Brown it is not do fate he does not do
phony he does genuine and real he has to
sit down and have a conversation with
Ashley that is not going to be pleasing
to her I don't think that they would
work outside of this environment and so
he has to sit down and break up with
Ashley